THOMAS FRANTZEN: Roar.
STEPHANIE WONG: Ah!
Dinosaur!
Or, wait.
Tom, is that you?
And weren't you in
Tokyo just last week?
THOMAS FRANTZEN:
Yes, which is why
I'm here to share my
excitement of Japan
and its classic movies.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
Can't wait for the sequel.
Maybe you'll be the
dinosaur and I'll
be the scientist, Dr. Wong.
Now, what are you going
to be demoing today?
THOMAS FRANTZEN:
Well, today I'm going
to be demoing a custom machine
learning API that leverages
Google's ML APIs, Vision,
Speech, Translation and Natural
Language.
But don't worry.
It's not going to turn into a
crazy chemical monster like me.
It's going to be an easily
integratable solution.
STEPHANIE WONG: Sweet.
Let's jump right into it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
THOMAS FRANTZEN: All right.
So what you're seeing
here on the left side
is a video stream.
This is actually
using something called
WebRTC, which is a
real-time communication
API released by Google.
And it pretty much allows you to
use the webcam in your computer
and in your web browser.
So we use those feeds
to actually drive
four different APIs.
And the first one that you
actually see is the Vision API.
So two features that come out--
that come out of the Vision
API are faces and labels.
Now, with faces what
we're actually using
is the-- we're trying to figure
out the emotional state out
of your face.
So if we smile, you're
going to see that it says,
joy is very likely.
So it provides cool
insight into kind
of your emotional
state of individuals
that you find within an image.
Another cool feature is Labels.
So Labels pretty much
identify different things that
are found within the image.
So in our case,
you know, there's
a forehead, or a socialite,
different-- a smile.
STEPHANIE WONG: I've finally
become Kim Kardashian, yes.
THOMAS FRANTZEN:
That's exactly right.
So you can use these to help
identify different things you
may find within an image.
So moving on to
the next API, which
is the Speech API, what
we actually did here
is we're using the
streaming Speech API.
And we took the audio stream
from the WebRTC video feed
and fed it through a websocket
to our compute engine
incense in the back end.
And with that, what we
can do is transcribe text
in relative real time.
So what that does is kind--
it pretty much opens up
the door to the other APIs that
are available through Google.
So for example, maybe you
want to do translation.
Maybe you're
speaking to somebody
in a different language.
So I was just in Japan.
What if you needed to
talk somebody in Japanese?
So with a Speech
API and Translate,
you're able to do this
in relative real time.
Pretty cool, right?
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
So once you get
into Text, then you
can use that as input
for Translation and NLP.
THOMAS FRANTZEN: Right.
Exactly.
Now NLP, Natural Language,
as I said, identifies
different objects
within your statement
and figures out what
kind of sentiment
do you have around that.
So like let's say, for
instance, I'm Godzilla.
I love Google Cloud Platform.
You'll see that down
on the bottom here
there's a whole bunch
of different objects
that it found important within
that statement, the importance
of those objects,
as well as kind
how you're feeling about it.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
Now we can tell just how
much people love Godzilla
and Google Cloud Platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Wow, Tom, for a
terrorizing dinosaur,
that was pretty awesome.
THOMAS FRANTZEN: Yeah.
I'm looking forward to
creating more concoctions
and demos in the future.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
I'm not sure if
you're going to be
able to do that with
your short, stubby arms.
But I guess we'll find out.
THOMAS FRANTZEN: Please comment,
like, and subscribe below.
STEPHANIE WONG: And if you
want to get in touch with us,
check out the link in
the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]